and I'll hawkish well this Celtic team
is a difference maker on both sides of
the floor defensively the Curia and
things a couple of tough guys down low
is Howie steps back nails the great
[Music]
diarrhea burgers ready to clean spins
gets in sight left hands and off the
glass Trina's average in ten eleven and
seven if you're an all-star for what you
do for your team's you're an all-star if
you're gonna just regard the numbers as
a coach you love them forever I know how
you can speak about Charles Oakes and
coaching him an all-star team I don't
agree with that I just think we need to
do a better job be consistent with the
thought process the selecting law as a
sweet move from Kyrie Irving
the referees need to get more calls
right and the players need to stop
acting like Kevin Durant wasn't one
range post up isolation situations he
can take the pressure off as Kyrie
Irving on the offensive end
curry launches sagging off the bigs of
Golden State's is they have clear
passing than me I don't mind
irving way downtown that's good the
clothes out there from place Thompson
Tatum Irving goes right it's a rant
scoop layup is good
he'd get more medicine that guy built
that a granite or what perfect fires
away Kyrie Irving seven for seven from
the field
19 points in 11 minutes the for all
stores in Iguodala out there parity ray
Tatom and Jalen Brown but he also said
he expects a different type of defense
he said the Warriors are great at mixing
it up and you've got it they've got to
be better at nine turnovers now for the
Celtics assets side beautiful look great
hurry back curry again perfect long
distance that's good Kyrie Irving curry
again to the basket school and maybe get
a call wrong is a player in out there
just respecting the guy is he coming on
from two boys and treating people with
respect thank you Steve
Kyrie Irving draws the foul shots good
disrespecting them talking to them
throwing the basketball at their legs
that mean that's not a speak saluting
March curry curry fires hurry
18 points here a little tip led by as
many as 10 here in the fourth quarter
curry to the basket high off the glass
points Irving drives stops left-handed
banks and hopefully better hurry for a
late Thompson crowds Irving gets past
them scoop layup is good
Robert Cortland urban gets away from
draymond Green quickly to the basket
look out
[Applause]